PyTorch has emerged as the de facto standard for
machine learning and deep learning.
And I know a little bit about PyTorch, but I've brought in an
expert, Sahdev Zala,
to teach us all more about PyTorch.
So, Sahdev, what is PyTorch?
Hi Brad!So it's a framework for machine learning and deep learning.
And what I mean by that is
you can usePyTorch to build your models
because it provides you all of the building blocks.
It provides youall the functionalities
to run faster training on that model.
And it's an open source project underPyTorch Foundation,
which is part of the Linux Foundation.
So there is a dynamic community behindthe project.
Oh, great! So it's got an ecosystem and it's in the Foundation.
So that means you'regoing to have open governance
and a level playing field. That's wonderful.
Well, Sahdev, can you tell
me about the key features of PyTorch?
Yeah, sure. That's a great question.
So let me just mention
the common steps of model training.
So first, you need to prep your data,
your data set fortraining.
And, ideally you also want to do it for testing.
And then, the other steps is you're
going to build your model.
And you're going to train it.
And as I mentioned, you're goingto test.
Okay. So those look like some
pretty straightforward features.
Why don't you tell meabout the first one?
What do you mean by prepping the data?
Right. So, the data says are you going to use
for your model, maybe small as you're learning it,
but for larger models, these data sets can
be huge--10 terabytes, petabytes wide.
So how do you use this data
to train your model andthen test it?
So PyTorch provides you two things here.
Data sets and data loader classes that help
you to easily feed this data for your training and testing.
Okay. How does this help me?
Does it speed things up?
Well, that's a good question. So, it helps you to download
the data to make itaccessible for your training and testing.
And this data loader, it provides you iterator over this
data so that you can use them to train in a batch.
Because you're not going to just feed one data
at a time. You're going to train using the batch sizes that you want.
It also provides you otherthings like shuffling the data.
You don't want to just feed the data in an order so that yourmodel,
it's only memorizing the data versus versus it's learning.
So this will shuffle for you as well.
It has other features as well.
Very nice. Well, it also helps you to build models?
Absolutely. So,once you think you're ready with your preparation
using PyTorch because it takes you all the takes
care of all the complexity, the next step would
be and building the model to define your models
and for that what you need is layers because it's
a deep learning, it's made of multiple layers.
So you need different layers like linear layer or
combination layer. And there are many others that
are provided by partners to you. And that are also
things like, besides layers, that are activation
functions that you'll be using to add nonlinearity
to your model-- that's also provided to you by
PyTorch. So you don't have to do anything but
just to call those functions.
What do youmean by nonlinearity?
So, in general,when you train the model and then-- it's a
mathematical term, right, linear as well,
but it will if you don't get nonlinear, you
basically just get like a one straight line.
And in real life, not everything is just
changing in X will be same as changing your Y
output. So it adds you that nonlinearity for
you. And the next step would be training and there
basically I can talk more about the training side, Brad.
Well, so tell me about features--
whatdoes it do to help you train?
So training willrequire to use the loss function. And loss function
is basically to find out the loss that you going
to have. As when you run this model like
a forward pass from the input and you get some
output. Well, I'm not going to have the correct output
every time magically, there's no magic there. So
you can have lots of parameters in between, youare
just going to randomize them in the beginning,
you got some output, but then you're going to
have a loss function to calculate the loss from
the desired output.
So your want your model to reach a certain expectation.
And typically duringthe training process that model's falling short
and you're seeing how much it's falling short
from where you want it to be.
Exactly. So that loss functions, there are multiple loss
functionsand PyTorch provides it to you again. You again
you call them according to your need for
the model. Once you have the loss function used,
the next big thing is finding the gradient of this
loss with regards to your parameters. So PyTorch
provides the backward propagation for you, or,
auto-grade features. That is by far one of the
most popular feature of PyTorch, that it will
calculate the gradient for you.
So if we allthink back from our calculus days, gradients are
this piece that helps you to tweak and
get the model the way you want it and it's got
it built-in for you.
Exactly. So once you gotthe gradient, you basically
run the optimizerfunction just to step over, which is again
provided by PyTorch to you. And like you exactly
said, you're going to tweak the parameters, you're
going to optimize it to reach to a level in a
number of iterations. So that you basically define
those iterations. But the number of iterations
you're going to reach to a level where we're like,
you know what, that should be enough training.
I do like 3x, 5x iterations, and at that point
you are ready to test it.
And is that a big dealfor these models
to have to do testing or I justtest once I'm done? Or is it more more than that?
Yeah. So the next step would be no. From here to the test side. You need to test it. Ideally it'soptional. But as part of testing, PyTorch provides
a function, an eval evaluation. So you can
evaluate your model. And at that point, you're not
going to calculate the gradient, you're not going
to find the loss function. You basically just do
the forward pass. You see what you're getting. And
if you're happy with it, then pretty much ready
to use the model. If you're not, then you're
going to do the further training. And again,
this data sets, which I mentioned earlier, that
would be used for training useful test, white or
black are two different datasets.
So aspart of the testing. I'm getting to decide, hey,
is my model good enough? I think I'm readyto go with it.
Pretty much, yeah.
Well, it all seems a little complicated to me.
Is PyTorch really easy to use?
Well, yes,that's one of the best things I love about PyTorch.
It's easy to get started. It's easy to install.
It's easy to use because it's Pythonic; the "Py"
in PyTorch is for Python. So you know how much
data scientists just love Python. Absolutely.
PyTorch is in Python. And it's been easily I use
by data scientists. And if someone if they don't
know Python, they can learn it quickly as well.
PyTorch.org provides a lot of good documentation,
tutorials that will help you to get started very
quickly and it's also flexible. So I mentioned
the training on your right. You can run training,
you can run your PyTorch on CPU just
using the tensor that PyTorch uses in
data structure (multi-dimensional
arrays). They can be run on CPUs,
they can be run on GPUs, they can do the training
on multiple CPU and GPU on a single machine,
you can do that on a distributed environment on
multiple machines, multiple GPUs. And you can
like say part of that you can just run PyTorch on
your laptop and play with it. There is also like
a mobile development going on to to help PyTorch
on your mobile devices.
So yeah, it's a lot ofoptions. Supports a lot of platforms. GPUs.
CPUs. Well, what if I want to be a contributor?
Well, that's great question. Something I love as
an contributor myself, so it's actually very easy.
PyTorch is part of PyTorch Foundation as I
mentioned. There's a dynamic community behind it,
very friendly. Lots of people are going to help
you to get started, to contribute. As long as you
sign the CLA, follow the code of conduct, these
are things to do. You are ready to contribute.
The community also provides weekly office hours.
Office hours, that's huge. I can come in as
a newperson and say, hey, could you help me out
or canyou give me an easy first item to work on?
I could do that in an office hours.
Yes, exactly. Andthere are things like you can easily
find the goodfirst issues. You can find the document issues to
get started with and you can ask questions.
Andthe office hours, through their Slack channel is another one.
And one of the classic tips iswhen you join a new project,
ask for a mentor and ask them to put you to work on something. Because
when they put you to work on something, they're
going to be very interested in what you're doing
and they're going to give you timely reviews and
answer all your questions. So tell me more about
how IBM is contributing to PyTorch.
Yeah, sure.
Well, IBM is contributing to PyTorch in a big way,
like IBM always do. By using PyTorch, so we are
going to contribute to help the community, grow
the community. And a part of that, we working on
many different things, something called like FSDP,
Fully Sharded Data Parallel, well, an advanced topic,
but it helps you to shard the model parameters
across multiple GPUs across multiple machines
forfast training and for your
large models they may not fit in like a single GPU
or CPU. And so we are contributing there. There's
really good blog posts out there. Just search
for it, "IBM FSDP PyTorch" wiil find it quickly.
Highly recommend to read it. We also provide
improvements in the storage site for training,
compiler optimizations. And besides that benchmarking,
test side improvements and documentation.
And we have multiple developers working in the
community.
So it sounds like there's lots ofnice features to help it
support those largefoundation models, supporting multiple GPUs
and running in a distributed fashion. And
a lot of work being done for benchmarking,
seeing how fast things are running and obviously
a lot of work in the documentation to help others
get started. It's a fabulous. It is.
It's amazing.I'm so glad to be part of the community.
Well, thank you, Sahdev. I've learned a lot today. This
is fabulous. We hope that you've learned a lot
about PyTorch and we encourage you to come
join the community. We really enjoy working
on PyTorch and pushing forward with your deep
learning/machine learning initiatives.
Thanks for watching our video. And don't forget, if you
liked it, remember to hit like and subscribe.